[Music]
hi guys
okay so second day of Fashion Week I got
this incredible German Kandra
this is also interesting too beautiful
to share and learn a source folder
Eclipse volumes from Calais beam and
make sure I'm absolutely freezing my
hopeless gorgeous all saved maybe - I
think so let go this cheer the day to do
the dog show I think of it to show the
last probably five seas and it's always
one of my favorite dresses are always
incredible and everything I'm here to
get more and more beautiful
- all done as Angela doesn't show to ask
the usefulness always like stunning
talak Oh so on the way home now I'm
going to get ready for this
so tonight is the versus assertion show
so I am wearing two pieces from mrs. so
I've got these gorgeous white light gun
and really cut up jeans on that have
this cool silver backing underneath
that's really nice and that runs through
this top as well as a super cool shape
and yeah it's gone really grungy with my
hair and make them really like it
[Music]
okay so gay three and Fashion Week today
is the pre-show so confidence Gorda
screening at bodysuit really rich
beautiful colors cooked it into the
score just kind of emerald green forest
green skirt from reef and then just some
black accessory so like my black zombie
tail Rocky
[Music]
we're on our way guys with tiny bit late
welcome to the al Qaeda Dino show
[Music]
really kind of chef I love Santa - ohso
bullet silence meal fish good
[Music]
it was very different and it was like
the other companies life our way now to
preen show on my rusty tomorrow right so
it's a second outfit of day three going
to a few new shows so I'm wearing the
gorgeous white suit from visas gorgeous
white laser white trousers joining
Malone junior shoes again lovely pops of
metallic I have my Fendi sunglasses if I
need them probably not the weather's
awful and it's stunning new mulberry
Bayswater bachelor
[Music]
okay I'm sick home I changed my makeup
so outfit to the day and we're going to
some amazing shows like Topshop mulberry
can play Oh in Malone's New Year as well
so it's going to be good partner day so
on the way to the cultural show made
here on time so please see I release
ironic it's always beautiful every
single season I usually buy everything
at people come out
[Music]
seiga kaku is absolutely beautiful
I've looked into anime absolute favorite
it is cz from Hello October
yeah tomorrow in area I think he's like
a [ __ ] karna oh my god this is amazing
I know that were you Center for lunch
and we're on our way now to celebration
I'm so excited
I know me too Angela
[Music]
take official in the Motor Show which
was absolute beautiful as I mentioned it
would be some money bags for the new
season art there will be for the sun-god
quilting and vehicle textures it was a
gorgeous show okay so it's not the end
of day three and Fashion Week I really
hope you enjoyed following me along some
film fun thank you so much for watching
if you'd like to see more videos like
this and make sure you subscribe down
below so glam in UK if you might see
more from me I am just in the throat on
YouTube and what thank you so much again
[Music]